foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jennifer Lopez proves she's not only
she's also the coolest Mama on the Block
too you know you just you balance it out
it's like every working Mama on Thursday
JLo hit up scissors concert in LA but
her hubby Ben Affleck wasn't her date
maybe they'll be embarrassed to me the
triple threats plus one her 15 year old
kiddo Emmy whom she shares with her ex
Marc Anthony Jennifer posted this clip
to Instagram smiling ear to ear
alongside the caption seeing your kids
happy priceless this was right before I
got the death stare to stop filming
[Music]
Emmy's twin brother Max wasn't in
attendance but an eyewitness spotted the
duo at the show having a great time kind
of living in the moment and feeling
really happy that's JLo rocking an
oversized fur and sunglasses dancing
waving and blowing kisses
[Applause]
but she wasn't the only celeb in the
crowd Timbaland Justin Timberlake and
Jessica Beale were there too
and there was star power on stage two
when lizzo surprised the crowd by
joining sza to sing their remix of
special
[Music]
bye back to Jennifer thank you thank you
last month Emmy and Max whom JLo
lovingly calls her coconuts turned 15.
Jen celebrated with a touching tribute
on Instagram set to what else Taylor
Swift's classic hit
[Music]
in the caption Jen shared a heartfelt
message for her kids I am so proud of
you both in every single way you bring
so much joy and happiness to my heart
and soul I love you beyond forever and
Max and Emmy are getting so big they're
all right they are they are so big and
so amazing and happy
foreign
[Music]
's Dynamic with Ben's children Violet
Seraphina and Samuel whom he shares with
his ex Jennifer Garner Azores previously
told E.T that the five kids are doing
great and get along effortlessly we're
super happy
um what can I tell you they all really
have respect for each other Jennifer's
relationship with Ben's kids is natural
and same goes for Ben's bond with
Jennifer's kids
[Music]
thank you